[Music]
you have a movie that's coming up uh
called the lucky one has not been
released yet but you
got in crazy shape for this movie
apparently i did i did you worked out
with like a navy seal is that right yes
i was playing marine but i trained with
the navy seal um he was crazy his name's
logan and uh
it was a pretty intense process a lot of
training
and believe it or not the hardest part
was physically eating that amount of
food i had to put on about 17 pounds and
you had to put on 17 pounds and just so
people understand this isn't like eat
doughnuts 17 pounds this is muscle we
have a photo here of you uh take it down
don't put that up i'm on the show yeah
okay that's okay it is awkward
we photoshopped your head onto my body
yeah no thief
completely different skin tone than mine
uh okay so that is 17th that has got to
be first of all
how do you do that i'd like to know how
does one do that
it was crazy i mean aside from the
training which which was
literally it was it consumed my life for
a while um
very intense a lot of a lot of heavy
lifting i won't give you that it's
boring the hardest part was eating you
know you just have to eat a ton a ton of
calories and it was all hard hard
calories it was a lot of chicken breasts
i was eating so much chicken breast
the hardest part about it was actually
chewing it all so i would just put it
into a blender blend it all up and just
drink chicken isn't that gross
i've never heard of someone blending
chicken i had never heard of it either
but i did it and it worked
i bet if you put tequila in that
quite good
all right so that sounds disgusting and
then what kind of things does this navy
seal have you doing is it working with
all kinds of machines or is this like
old-school stuff no it's it's a well
it's a mix it's old-school stuff i mean
it's it's pretty cutting-edge he knows
what he's doing um
i remember the first day i was in pretty
good shape when i came into this movie i
was skinnier but i was in good shape and
i thought oh you know i know what i'm
doing here
he wanted to make sure that i left my
ego at the door so one of our first days
of training he was like all right 200
pull-ups 200 push-ups and you're done
and then he just walked out
and i was left there to do 200 pull-ups
oh that day i thought you meant
throughout the whole six-month period
if i could do two a day i'd be okay
i'm done for today where's my custard
you know